[Musique]
maintenant lorsqu'on achète un poulet
entier à l'épicerie clip vide à
l'intérieur il ya plus de coeur de foi
de gésiers ou de rognon et vous nous
avez demandé pourquoi y avait plus ses
abattis c'est parce que les supermarchés
répondre à la demande des clients vous
êtes trop nombreux à ne pas vouloir de
ces matières moins nobles de la volaille
mais sachez que vous ne payez pas pour
le vide la volaille étant rendue au kilo
vous pouvez les acheter séparément
auprès de votre boucher en épicerie ou
chez les marchands spécialisés mais
sachez qu'il est plus difficile d'en
trouver parce que il ya manque de main
d'oeuvre pour trier et un sachet c'est
parti les abattis ne sont toutefois pas
gaspiller plus qu'on les utilise pour
faire de la nourriture pour les animaux